Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
♪♪
We are right in the middle
of the holiday season,
and I saw that Instacart
is now offering
same-day delivery
for Christmas trees.
[ Laughter ]
So remember to tip,
because your delivery guy
definitely has an ax.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, wow.
Of course, it's Instacart, so
get ready for a text that says,
"They're out of Christmas trees.
Is Pepsi okay?"
And you go, "Pepsi?
That's not even --"
Yep, Christmas trees
on Instacart.
It's a beautiful
new family tradition
of gathering around papa
until he swipes right
on the perfect balsam fir.
"Dad's getting his phone out.
Come on, let's gather up."
I don't want someone else
picking out my Christmas tree.
I don't even like someone else
picking out my cantaloupe.
I was like, "Oh.
You thought that was ripe?
Didn't you knock on it?"
Is that what you do with
a cantaloupe?
Do you knock on it?
-You got to thwap the end.
You smell it. You know.
-Certain things I just knock on
and think I know
what I'm talking about.
Do you knock on a pineapple?
That does nothing.
You peel the leaf of
a pineapple.
-You pull the leaf.
-Watermelon I knock on,
of course.
That goes without saying.
-Knock on wood.
-I knock on watermelons
I don't even buy.
I just go up and go,
"Hey, what's up?"
[ Laughter ]
-Fill it with vodka.
-Yeah, yeah.
Did you guys see this?
New York just passed a law that
makes all gift cards
purchased in the state
valid for at least nine years.
-Ooh!
-You know you got someone
the perfect gift card
when it takes them 8 1/2 years
to use it.
"Well, you like
Home Depot, so..."
8 1/2 -- Yeah.
They're good for nine years,
although I'm not quite sure
what to do with a valid gift
card from Borders Bookstore.
What am I doing?
Find me a Borders.
Let's get to some news.
Due to a rise in
COVID, RSV, and flu cases,
New York City health officials
issued an advisory
urging people
to wear masks again.
[ Audience groans ]
I think they're getting
tired of these announcements,
'cause this one felt a little
more casual than the rest.
Take a look at this.
That's...
-Wow.
-That was fast.
♪♪
That's it?
That was fast.
That's right -- New York City
is experiencing
high levels of
COVID, flu, and RSV,
and health officials are
calling it a "tridemic."
-Aw, come on, man.
We can do better than that.
-What's that, Tariq?
-I said we can come up with
a better name than a "tridemic."
That's so clunky.
-Yeah, you're right.
"Tridemic" doesn't even
rhyme with anything.
What are you thinking?
-Um, the three-sles.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good.
Scarlet three-ver.
-Uh...hepa-thri-tis.
-Gono-three-a.
-The thrice-capades.
-The thrice is right.
-Trip-slip.
-Fuzzy triple.
-Mm...
uh, "Three Strains and a Baby."
-"Three Strains and a Rabies."
-[ Laughs ]
-Once, twice, three
types of achy.
-The Tri Guys.
-We can just call it
"Three's Company."
-How about "All I Want for
Christmas is Achoo"?
-Rocking around
a Christmas three.
-Oh. The tres race.
-Ooh! The tres force.
-Left without a tres.
-All aboard the flu-flu strain
choo-choo train.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's it.
That's the one. That's it.
Tariq Trotter got it right.
[ Dinging ]
That's it, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, guys,
Elon Musk is still on his
"trying to make
people upset" tour.
And Elon is being slammed
for a tweet
he posted yesterday that said...
Fauci was like, "Yep,
much like a Tesla battery,
Elon's on fire."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. You could tell Fauci
wasn't having it
because he wrote back,
"Congrats on making Twitter
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine
of social media."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Meanwhile, Elon also said that
Twitter's character limit
for tweets is going to increase
from 280 to 4,000.
People are like,
"4,000 characters?
At that point, I may as well get
my news from the news."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
King Charles just released
the first royal
Christmas card of his reign.
Ready for it? Here it is.
"Wishing you a very happy
Christmas and New Year."
It has the same
emotional feeling
as a holiday card
from your dentist.
[ Laughter ]
"I can see through this."
Seriously, the love and emotion
just flows from that guy's pen.
Are there budget cuts
at Buckingham Palace?
Is that --
Is Elon firing everyone
in the card division over there?
Well, here's some big news.
The other day, a lot of people
were surprised to
see Ben Affleck getting coffee
at Starbucks.
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Ben Affleck was
drinking Starbucks,
and it didn't take long for
Dunkin' to respond.
Watch this.
-Well, well.
You think you're better than us,
Benedict Affleck?
You think you're wicked smart
going to Starbucks,
sipping $6 drinks like
the freaking King of England?
Enjoy your foam in a dome,
you L.A. jabron.
Just go ahead and go.
Tom Brady left us,
and we're fine.
We still got Matt Damon
and a half-dozen Wahlbergs.
We'll bounce back,
even if we feel the way
Bill Belichick looks.
-Oh! That's so sad. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Guys, we are right in the middle
of the holiday season.
Are you excited?
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a survey,
during the holidays,
most dog owners
buy a gift for their pet.
Yeah.
And then there's the people
that are too lazy to shop
and just give their dog cash.
[ Laughter ]
Buying a gift for a dog
is stressful.
I mean, seriously,
there's nothing more depressing
than watching your dog
open a present
then fake wagging his tail.
[ Laughter ]
You go, "Okay.
He didn't like it. Okay."
Let's get to some news.
Today, President Biden
hosted a ceremony
on the South Lawn
to sign a bill that mandates
federal recognition
for same-sex marriages.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
When he heard,
Mike Pence was like,
"Barkeep, give me a shot
of whole milk."
[ Laughter ]
"Just leave the whole carton."
Yeah, the bill protects
all marriages.
Unless you're
one of those couples
who feed each other in public.
Then you're on your own.
[ Laughter ]
I read that Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner
cut ties
with former president Trump
because he's "losing value"
and they don't need him anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's not even upset.
He's like, "The student
has become the master."
[ Laughter ]
Things are so rough
in the Trump family,
even the royal family's like,
"Yikes."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this today?
A bipartisan group of lawmakers
announced a bill
that would ban TikTok
in the U.S.
-[ Person whistles ]
[ Laughter ]
Right now, gen Z is like,
"We ride at dawn."
[ Laughter ]
Critics of TikTok worry that the
app is giving American secrets
to the Chinese government.
Yeah, pretty scary.
Apparently, China has already
mastered the "Wednesday" dance.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, get this,
a TikTok-famous plastic surgeon
just had her
medical license suspended
after she was accused
of botched surgeries.
See, that's why I only use
YouTube-famous plastic surgeons.
[ Laughter ]
When asked for a comment,
she said,
"Look, I don't see them
as botched surgeries.
I look at them as cool filters."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, New York City
is experiencing high levels
of COVID, flu, and RSV
in what health officials
are calling a "tridemic."
And Pfizer is promoting
a new booster shot
to protect against it.
Check this out.
-As cases continue to rise,
experts recommend
getting the latest boosters
for COVID, the flu, and RSV.
But as the holidays approach,
we might not all have time
for multiple appointments.
That's why we're introducing
The Destroyer.
Just one quick jab,
and you're protected from...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow, indeed!
-Wow!
Multiple injections.
Oh, my goodness.
Firecrotch, unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I want to say
happy birthday to Bob Barker
who just turned 99!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you, Bob.
You could tell he hosted
"The Price is Right"
'cause that's the closest
you can come to 100
without going over.
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
Uber Eats released
its annual Cravings Report,
which revealed
the hottest
food-ordering trends of 2022.
And the trends
were pretty interesting.
For example,
more people requested
celery juice on Wednesdays.
-Oh. Man, see, I always ordered
celery juice on Wednesday.
-Yeah. On Friday, there's
a spike in cannoli orders.
-Wow! I get cannolis, you know,
every Friday, too.
That's crazy.
-Yeah, well, apparently, orders
of ranch dressing went way down.
-Ha! See, I didn't order
any ranch this year.
[ Laughter ]
-And the big drink craze
was a negroni sbagliato.
-Sbagliato, you say.
Those are good.
The only thing better
is a margarita.
It goes great with a steak.
[ Laughter ]
-It makes sense.
I mean, the most frequently
paired food/drink combo
was steak and margarita.
-Huh.
[ Ominous music plays ]
Really?
W-What about Saturdays?
I got to be the only one
who orders tater tots
and says to hold the --
-Sour cream.
[ Laughter ]
Dammit.
-W-What?
What's wrong, Tariq?
-No, it -- it can't be.
-What?
W-- What is it?
-No way, n-not me.
-Say it.
What is it, Tariq?
[ Dramatic music crescendos ]
-I think I might be
a basic bitch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause continues ]
-Or you're a trendsetter.
-Damn right I am!
-Whew!
I was worried for a second.
Guys, I heard about --
a new study found that people
who wake up with an alarm clock
are more tired than people
who wake up naturally.
Another reason people who use
an alarm clock are tired --
they have jobs.
[ Laughter ]
This is wild.
An Olive Garden manager
was fired
after sending the staff
an aggressive warning
about missing work.
Listen to this.
-The message from
an Olive Garden manager
in Kansas to employees.
[ Laughter ]
-Good news, though --
today, she was hired to be
the head of H.R. at Twitter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good news.
Yeah, it all works out.
♪♪
We're very excited here, guys.
Christmas is only 11 days away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, last week, you went,
"How much for shipping?"
And now it's like,
"$59.99 and my first born?
Let's do this. Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Get this --I saw a new survey
that said New Yorkers'
least-favorite Christmas food
is peppermint bark.
[ Laughter ]
I like peppermint bark.
I do.
I especially like
how the chocolate soothes
the open wounds caused
by the shards of candy cane.
[Gravelly voice]
"Merry Christmas."
[Normal voice]
The survey also found
the most popular
Christmas food is...
-Ritz crackers.
-Ritz crackers? No.
[ Laughter ]
That's not Christmas food.
Ritz crackers?
I mean, it's a food, sure.
It's like...
Pigs in a blanket.
[ Audience oohs ]
Jesus was like, "Thanks for
keeping my birthday classy.
Appreciate it."
Pigs in a blanket.
Apparently on Christmas,
people ask themselves,
"What would Jesus'
brother-in-law Randy do?"
I read that right now --
I love --
By the way,
I love pigs in a blanket.
-I'm all for it.
-I'm all for it, man.
I read that right now
the cost of ingredients
for popular holiday desserts
is surging.
Thankfully, every family
has that same blue tin
of Danish butter cookies
that's been floating around
for 20 years.
"We didn't finish these yet?
How come no one's eating
these square ones
with no sugar on them?"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
According to a poll,
one-third of Americans
start buying holiday gifts
two months in advance.
That's risky 'cause a lot
can happen in two months.
It's like, "Here's that Kanye
sweatshirt you wanted."
You go, "Hey. Wait. Hold on."
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
"Put it in the box."
♪♪
Speaking of presents,
this year,
75% of people said they plan to
buy gifts from small businesses.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Small businesses.
When they heard that,
Santa's elves were like,
"One more short joke,
and I'm gonna cut somebody!"
And you go, "No, no.
It's not a shor--
Small businesses."
75% of people want to shop
at small businesses,
which explains this ad I saw.
-Oh, really?
-This holiday season, support
your local mom-and-pop shop --
Amazon!
We know what you're thinking.
How does a "family business"
have 800,000 employees?
Easy. We're all cousins.
That's not a warehouse.
That's a family reunion.
Get back to work, family.
-Yeah. Aww. Mom-and-pop.
[ Applause ]
Well, let's get to some news.
President Biden has reportedly
vented to allies
over how much the media
talks about his age.
And at one point he even said,
"You think I don't know
how F'ing old I am?"
[ Laughter ]
This is a real thing. Yeah.
His staff was like,
"Of course you do,
but just to be safe,
toss out a number."
[ Laughter ]
"Higher."
Yeah. Biden was furious.
It only got worse
when his chief of staff said,
"Well, he hasn't had
his nap today, so..."
Biden was upset. He cursed.
He ran up to his bedroom,
slammed the door,
cranked up Bing Crosby.
"You don't know me!"
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news.
Since announcing his 2024 run,
former President Trump
has been relatively quiet,
but today he said that he's
planning a major announcement
and posted this video.
This is real.
We didn't make this.
Take a look.
[ Dramatic music swells ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Jimmy:
"Major announcement."
[ Laughter ]
"Major..."
-God.
-Is he announcing Dean Cain
as his running mate?
I don't know what he's --
I think the major announcement
is that Trump
has a lot of time on his hands.
Okay.
Right after that was released,
Ron DeSantis' poll numbers
shot up another 20 points.
Can we see that picture again?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
Let's be real.
If Trump tore his shirt open,
we'd probably see
five layers of Spanx.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Switching gears, apparently
the IRS has been contacting
OnlyFans creators as part
of a criminal tax investigation.
-Ooh.
-The IRS actually said they're
sending two agents at a time --
one to do the investigation
and the other to make sure
that the first guy
is actually doing
the investigation.
[ Laughter ]
Get this.
Mark Zuckerberg is spending
so much time and money
on the Metaverse
that employees are worried
that he's going to
destroy the company.
Well, here to clear things up,
live, via satellite,
is Mark Zuckerberg. Mark?
-Hey, Jimmy. Don't mind me.
Just gonna be chilling
in the Metaverse
while we do this interview.
-Okay, sure.
Mark, these are pretty serious
allegations from your employees.
How do you respond to them?
-What you're hearing in
the press is really overblown.
We're investing a lot
in the Metaverse, sure,
but don't worry.
I'm giving it my full attention.
[ Club whacks ball ]
Ugh! Sliced it!
-But your -- But your company
lost $80 billion worth
of stock value.
Do you have any ideas
on how to fix this?
-Trust me, Jimmy. $80 billion
is a drop in the bucket.
We'll gain it all right back.
Cinnamon! Cinnamon, notice me!
Notice me! Cinnamon!
-"Cinnamon, notice..."
-What?!
-I think that's
all the time we have.
Mark Zuckerberg, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Take care, Jimmy.
-Alright...
Alright.
Guys, I heard
that the CEO of Taco Bell says
gen Z wants to eat chicken
instead of beef.
[ Cheers ]
Then they added,
"But it doesn't affect us
'cause what we serve
is technically neither."
[ Laughter ]
You're all clear.
Don't worry about it.
Whatever you want. It's both.
That's how I remember.
I had the lasagna. Yeah.
Some more business news.
Costco is planning
to raise the price
of their annual membership.
-Ooh.
-[ Audience boos ]
-Yeah, Costco is
getting more expensive,
and you can tell
they're a little fancier now.
Watch this ad I saw.
-Welcome to ze new Costco.
Ze home of elegance.
A seven-pound bucket of Nutella.
Sophistication.
Turtlenecks and batteries
on the same aisle.
And class.
Old people eating hot dogs.
Costco. Like Walmart
with a doorman.
-That's...
That's interesting, I thought.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Costco."
-You guys --
Have you guys seen this?
The newest trend being
brought back in style
is the lower-back tattoo.
[ Audience groans ]
As we speak, a bunch
of 40-year-old guys are like,
"Maybe a calf tattoo of Calvin
peeing isn't far behind?"
Yep, lower-back tattoos
are back.
Well, now I think we know what
Trump's big announcement is.
Yeah.
"Check out my Trump stamp."
[ Applause ]
♪♪
You guys, we are just 10 days
away from Christmas.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right,
just 10 more days
and 900 more e-mails
from Amazon.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's --
Let's get to some news.
Yesterday,
former President Trump said
that he was going to make
a "major announcement,"
and today he did exactly that.
And this is real.
I'm not --
[ Laughter ]
We did not make this.
We've not -- We did not do this.
This is a real thing.
-Oh, boy.
-Here is Trump's major
announcement. This is --
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Triumphant chorale plays ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Even the most diehard
Trump supporters were like,
"Okay, now I'm worried, okay?
This is --"
[ Laughter ]
Even the MyPillow guy was going,
"I think Trump's lost it, okay?"
[ Laughter ]
If you saw that at 2:00 am,
would you be like,
"Am I having an Ambien dream?"
[ Laughter ]
You know your campaign
isn't going well
when your re-election
strategy is --
[ As Trump ]
Maybe people will like me
as a Pokémon.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like --
[ As Trump ]
These cards are like
classified documents.
You got to catch them all.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
today in Washington,
a disciplinary council called
for Rudy Giuliani
to be disbarred.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rudy was like --
[ As Giuliani ]
Joke's on you. I never had
a license to begin with.
[ Laughter ]
After the ruling, Rudy said,
"Well, on to selling
baseball cards, alright."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, here's some big news --
First Lady Jill Biden
is reportedly now all-in
on the idea of her husband
running for a second term.
I mean, after watching
that Trump video,
how could she not be?
[ Laughter ]
Some more news
from Washington --
last night, the House passed
a short-term
government funding bill
to avert a shutdown, yeah.
Here, check out what some
members of the House had
to say about it. First up,
Congressman David Price said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And Congressman Josh Harder
said...
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Jeff Duncan said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
I just --
[ Applause ]
Then Congressman Ken Buck
said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Congressman Tom Cole
said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Congressman Virginia Foxx
said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Congressman
Dutch Ruppersberger said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone had --
Everyone but him.
-Had their say.
♪♪
Did you see this?
This is this is real, as well.
TLC just announced
a new reality dating show
called "MILF Manor."
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh!
-It features eight women,
eight younger men,
and one shocking twist.
Yeah, I think
the shocking twist is
that TLC used to stand
for The Learning Channel.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Claps ]
-Actually, the shocking twist is
that it's hosted by Mike Pence.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Well, I saw that
several TikTok users
have been posting
their own Tinder Wrapped, okay?
Where they wrap up
their year of dating.
Yeah, and a lot of them
were very similar,
so, since it's the holidays,
I'll sum them all up
in the most festive way
possible. Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ "The Twelve Days of Christmas"
plays ]
[ Bells jingling ]
♪ In the last day of Tinder ♪
♪ My love life gave to me ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Joins in singing ]
What a year.
♪♪
Thank you very much.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thanks, Steph.
Guys, I read a new survey
that said
the most stressful place to be
during the holidays is the mall.
-Hm.
-It's so stressful,
shoppers are walking
up to mall Santas like,
"Let me get a swig of that."
♪♪
I'm in a great mood
because we're right
in the middle
of the holiday season.
Christmas is almost here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Hanukkah starts on Sunday.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hanukkah is celebrated
for eight nights,
so the next time you complain
about your relatives
at Christmas,
times that by eight.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, people are still
shopping for presents,
and I heard that, this year,
one of the most unwanted gifts
is beauty products.
That makes sense.
You can't hand someone
a bag of make-up like,
"I thought you needed this."
[ Laughter ]
Well, in a recent survey,
for the second year in a row,
New Hampshire ranked
as the state
with the most Christmas spirit.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Vermont was like,
"Excuse me.
We have the
Ghost of Christmas Past.
Hello."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Last night, several
high-profile journalists
who have been covering Elon Musk
had their
Twitter accounts suspended.
Elon said the journalists
were using social media
to keep track
of what he's doing,
or as that's also known,
social media.
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling that,
right after Christmas,
we're gonna see Elon Musk in
line trying to return Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
It's a big weekend for sports,
'cause this Sunday
is the World Cup final
between Argentina and France.
Argentina and France.
Of course,
my bracket's already busted.
I had England and Gonzaga
in the final.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Argentina versus France.
At first, I wasn't sure
what was at stake,
but then someone told me
it's like "Evita"
versus "Les Mis."
And I was like, "Oh, I get it."
[ Laughter ]
The final will be played
on Sunday at 10:00 a.m.,
so if you want to know
why soccer isn't more popular
in America, there's your answer.
[ Laughter ]
Well, everyone's
talking about this.
13 years after the original,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
has finally hit theaters.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is wild.
The movie has a run time
of 3 hours and 12 minutes.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That's not a movie,
that's a flight.
[ Laughter ]
Even Hanukkah is like, "Whoa.
How long we doing this?"
[ Laughter ]
If this was on Netflix,
the "Are you still watching?"
thing would pop up 48 times.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, I'm still watching."
I read that, this weekend,
screenings of
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
are selling out
all across the country,
especially at IMAX theaters.
And I think I know why.
Check out this ad I just saw.
-You've never seen anything like
the underwater world of Pandora.
And in honor of
"Avatar: The Way of Water,"
IMAX has something else
you've never seen before.
Introducing FLYMAX,
the first large-format urinal,
designed to handle your stream
after a 44-ounce Icee
and a 3-hour movie about water.
Just zip and let 'er rip
as a cascade of blue liquid
take yours urine on
the adventure of a lifetime.
-Whoo!
FLYMAX, by IMAX.
Putting the "Aaa" in "Avatar."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that makes sense.
[ Applause ]
Some business news --
for the next three days,
Starbucks union members
will strike at 100 locations.
Yep, on the other hand,
that means the other
40,000 Starbucks will still
be open for business.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A Panera customer went viral
on TikTok after she discovered
that the chain's
Charged Lemonade drink
contains more caffeine
than four espressos.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Panera was like,
"Well, you're gonna to need it
after eating a mac-and-cheese
bread bowl."
[ Laughter ]
After a few sips, she was like,
"Do you also hear EDM music?
Oh, never mind.
That's just my heart."
♪ En, en, en, en ♪